bon alors il va nier bonsoir café
l'équivalent de 200 longs métrages et
qu'après les globe-trotters père resté
sept ans sans rien faire après
boulangeât des guerriers dans ces tentes
c'est aussi ce n'est pas ce que je pense
et on sait par cet enjeu changer
d'appartement tous les sept anges
oui les milieux pro terre 68,75 moulin
c'est à dire sept ans et ensuite j'ai
fait moulin pendant sept ans ouais
puisqu'en 82 et 81 2
à 89 donc si tu veux je vais recommencer
enfin 88 n'atteint pas cet essai après
c'est après quoi c'est un peu les
globe-trotters péter partir go à jouer
aux hippies non j'avais découvert non
non moi je m'étais beaucoup baladé à fin
mai si tu veux les globe-trotters c'est
vrai que ça m'avait donné envie de
retourner dans les endroits où gérer et
effacés
ne restait pas suffisamment et puis
aller en pèlerinage mois il dit non aux
pèlerinages mari moi j'ai fait le tour
du mou c'est en fait c'est assez marrant
parce que j'ai dit partie au départ je
partais au mexique 1 1 et du mexique je
me suis retrouvé en un an même si ses
parents dans le chemin mais je suis
foutu c'est un peu loin je suis passé
par tahiti parfois par l'australie et
puis on s'est arrêté en indonésie bali
tuvalu dans 69 j'allais un peu plus être
à dix et puis ensuite le vietnam c'était
encore la fin de la guerre du vietnam le
cambodge puis j'ai eu la chance de voir
avant qu'ils soient détruits notamment
encore world tour à l alliance yade
non la hausse non à l'avant mais là où
c'était fermé et après tu allais souvent
aux états unis ah ben ouais moi j'avais
des des raisons
vtb une histoire d'amour j'avais 10 ans
de choeur avec les orgues
enfin maintenant on peut le dire mais
sur le moment ça m'en sers quoi j'avais
été bien non c'était pas ça le problème
sexuel j'étais moi j'étais marié j'étais
en train de me séparer de ma femme est
elle se séparait de son mari
c'était mes parents parlaient pas ça
c'est que par rapport à elle c'était
très gênant par rapport à mon niveau
c'était très gênant si ce qui fait que
c'est assez marrant complètement
anecdotique mais quand j'arrivais aux
états unis
pas que je montre mon droit ensemble
dans mon sort terre par exemple à new
york
j'ai vu new york venu d'en dessous que
j'ai décoché dans les limousines tu vas
compact les paparazzi
moi je voyais nuit en vue dans le show
et gallimard monnaie ce qui pèse pas
c'est elle qui t'a appelé un jour enfin
tu l'a appelée lui a demandé comment les
son maître nageur elle t'a dit commenté
non sans histoire et en afrique dans ses
bagages m'a téléphoné il était
5 heures du matin je vais prendre
l'avion le lendemain et comme ne savait
pas trop comment amener
la séparation et m'a demandé d'apporter
ma grand mère je suis tu m'appelles paca
dans les matins de parler d'eux mais bon
c'est là
arrivé au maître nageur maintenant j'ai
vu et revu mais oui en plus maintenant
les tricheries avec ça tu as rendu
triste je suis pas ouais c'est jamais
agréable
ces pannes de fait se faire larguer
c'est simplement je construis quand même
quelqu'un et puis avant ses talents des
cités sur banc
chez toi voyez une autre histoire fait
pas gay non plus et que tu as raconté
dans son bouquin qui s'appelle le parano
secte a été suivie par les frites
pendant ces cinq jours est ce que c'est
une déformation professionnelle est ce
que c'est à force de faire moulin ou ou
est ce qu'il y avait des vraies raisons
bien c'est ce que les flics m'ont dit
oui ils m'ont dit vous avez sans doute
trop
j'ai trop tourner le commissaire voilà
les temps à savoir des fils partout
donné tu étais pas on dit que c'est par
ado j'étais parano non pas du tout je
sais pas du tout à mon nom j'ai eu je
pense tu sais je suis par exemple ou
prendre le cas de françoise sagan je
pense que si tu veux velefique elle a
envie de c'était dans le c'était dans
l'air à ce moment là ne s'est pas réglé
des gens connus parce que c'est plus
c'est plus valorisant quand on reçoit
j'ai arrêté de françois saillant
ça c'est ça c'est ça à plat le
commissaire moulin je voyais un bon jeu
de mot mood paris j'ai envie de faire un
titre le journal dnes
enfin bref ils ont bien fait chier ils
m'ont bien fait chier ça ils auraient
quand même ça a duré quatre ans
c'était quoi c'était parce que tu avais
une maison ni biesheim
parce que si tu veux moi j'aime d'abord
je pense que j'ai pas eu que les flics
j'ai eu aussi les douanes et les douanes
sont plus ils sont plus tenaces nous les
flics et au départ je pense que c'est
parti du fait que
je voyageais beaucoup j'avais très
souvent aux états unis quand même
transport des urnes on ne pensait que si
tu veux j'ai des accointances des
rapports chez papa tu vois et je pense
que la parano ce qui est intéressant
d'entendre dans le bouquin j'ai écrit
cet apparat non en fait être se trouvent
elles se trouvent pas d'un seul côté je
devais souvent de votre côté parce que
du côté des flics
tout dépend d'éclairage et l'éclairage
que tu donnes choses ont été traversées
du désert te fait du doublage de film ça
je savais pas beaucoup quand tu doubles
et travolta dont elle a la charge le
disait récemment dans un match disait je
ne suis plus qu'une voie sèche est
devenu
vivendi au sol j'ai donné par logan mini
jeu mais le second la dent dans quinze
jours
et en chemin de terre qui va encore
avoir des histoires avec lui
je voulais avec les vrais policiers
journée c'était bizarre je ne fais que
des flics dans le dans dans frantic de
polanski je vole à boulay commissaire
l'art du
rick hunter tous les abonnés ckoi gym
technik pas du tout alors tu as fait un
film qui était très bien qui s'appelait
fait qu'un centrale avec aminé
casabianca s'est un peu fait chier qu'on
parle beaucoup d'elle
le film est sorti est-ce que tu y vois
là aussi la malédiction des prédictions
du tout non je pense que ça c'est une
question de personnalité et je pense que
camilla pas joué le jeu
nous on a fait ce film dans des
conditions tout à fait particulière
puisque on n'était même pas et on était
en participation moi je peux donner
j'ai pas honte de venir j'ai touché
comme cachet pour 12 in 4000 mal
ouais c'est pas mal
reghalal du smi donc si tu veux à partir
de ce moment là c'est comme un film de
copains j'ai tout on a participé j'ai
participé au scénario
j'aime en aparté gérer sauf à la
promotion et à la formation tout d'un
coup quand on entendait parler qu'à
minutes
elle ne parlait que d'elle
éventuellement de raymond depardon un
débat sera étonné vous du bruit de poser
la question de demander si c'était un
film de fiction ou si c'est un reportage
sur la gimone jeune fille
c'est pas une question je suis pas
cabosser visuels on me dit tu savais
quand tu as fait le film que c'était la
vie que patrick ouart va absolument
je ne suis pas de la regarder le journal
tandis que j'ai je trouve très
antipathique amant mais très
antipathique et je me suis dit il faut
que je rende ce personnage à la fois
antipathique les chaussettes il résister
mais il faut que je rende touchant parce
qu'ils ne peuvent pas être quand il m'a
dit tu mois et à partir du moment où je
grossis 16 tu veux les défauts du
personnage c'était certainement une
empathie nés dans les maquis et trouver
cette scène quand on quand on est dans
l'est dans le wagon et qu' il dit est
année je vais ranger tout ça entre temps
ils en chient qui se met à chier dans le
couloir ou une poubelle il pense que
c'était cherif hannachi
tu vois les uns c'est tellement énorme
c'est tellement gros que finalement
quelque part il est touchant
dans la mort il m'a il est incroyable
parce que moi je moi je suis blindé à
brader ce personnage c'est pas moi qui
ai écrit cette histoire c'est de me le
casabianca qui n'est pas rancunier parce
qu'on parle d'elle dans son livre l'imam
à ses jantes mnr elle avait envie de
régler ses comptes de l'allumer mais bon
elle m'a choisie en tant qu'interprète
j'ai exécuté les ordres c'est tout j'ai
peut-être mis un peu de temps je vais te
raconter là sont pressés ordinaire si on
fait la promotion de pcb
je fais deux émissions de télévision
sauf celle de bois d'arbre edwards avant
dit il est hors de question je prendrais
nié avant comment est-ce qu'on doit
demeurer un truc pareil
tout ça parce que tout d'un coup mais ce
que rayé intervenez poivre d'arvor il
faut à présent chose faite
il a pas la passion
il ya une autre affaire encore
commissaire à l'envi a lancé cette
affaire du sphinx bon va faire je me
suis je me suis à la sphère du sphinx je
te dire à faire du sphinx et allait
devenir le nouveau dieu le veut on
rentre c'est ça non non non mais enfin
bon c'est se déroule en deux temps on
propose ce truc en me disant mais en me
racontant si tu veux le le principe de
fonctionnement
moi je trouve ça sympa ils vont ainsi
reprendre de deux gars qui sont pas au
courant l'endroit où ils vont aller est
trimballé en chine et brésil et jouer
avec le vent vient ensuite heures nous
faire rêver en même temps ça s'arrache
massabrac principe moi je le trouve très
très bien
je vous dise à bon port en plus j'aime
bien voyager je vous dise et rajeuni
feront payer en plus c'est payé c'est
sympa et puis là dessus première bavure
prenez des ce sont des idées des
concurrents bilan bon d'accord ok je
comprends des ducs on prend la voiture
ou d'être d'accord berbinau bon deuxième
bavure à l'intérieur de ce jeu des
concurrents bidon
le producteur favorise
zack laboris sa copine en lui balançant
les questions elle super sympa
d'ailleurs elle se plante je pose une
question et demandant quel animal favori
suivant sa voix à l'écran ça veut dire
grosso une équipe les gens parce que
l'eau était bidon si tu vois mes cheveux
étaient bidons bijoux et y jouer pour de
bon dès mais quand il s'agit de gagner
un voyage fin à la sélection la maison
de la radio sur l'endroit idéal et gagne
bien sûr les juges de milan bon à ce
moment là ruth est venu le projecteur
est pris à partie on lui demande de
s'expliquer et il prouve
voilà les bras
29 une échappatoire le lendemain il se
pointe avec une est de la deûle à 10 ans
avouant qu'elle a trouvé des réponses
par terre comme ça qu'il veut rien et ce
qui fait un peu de mystère de la grande
guerre avec qu'est-ce qui se passe
l'équipe qu'avec avait un certain
pouvoir sur dans cette émission
dino terminé on travaille plus avec ce
maître un refus absolu que ceux qui
reviennent sur les plateaux
donc il se trouve basé de sa propre
émission un producteur et nuit il
essayait de récupérer son jeu aussi
récupérer son jeu il à dire et tout le
monde va dire que tous les gens qui ont
dénoncé le scandale désamour des huit
avions et white ont tous les deux cent
cinquante mille balles mon fils est sain
et rapide partout on dirait ils ont viré
les deux frangines les risques il
s'agirait tout le monde non en virer
tous les techniques aux tous les gens
qui avaient assisté à ce problème et qui
avait régalé tous les témoins tous les
coupables
voilà alors la suite de gomme et je me
suis retrouvé dans le bureau d'air froid
et faire 3 je leur dis bah écoutez pas
très bien je m'en vais en mairie jeudi
donne moi la raison pour laquelle je
pars li parce que vous ne correspondez
pas winter des files et chaleureux nanan
j'étais pas suffisamment culturel qui
alors pourrait me lire le nom de man en
passant dé marc menant 6 effectivement
l'emblème de la culture pas de problème
je m'en vais mais avant de partir je
vais même vous dire ce qui s'est basé
sur votre émission parce qu apparemment
vous avez pas le taux courant et je
balance tout ce que je viens de te
rappeler aux moyens mais j'ai eu un
petit peu étonné quand même parce que
c'est vrai qu'ils n'étaient pas au vent
et miss toute manière bon d'accord
effectivement c'est grave on s'en fout
j'ai donc je peux pas lancé à la presse
en fait on s'en fout et body dont se
fait pas cher le faire comme ça
t'as pas l'impression que ça y est
maintenant je ne tire pas dans les
conditions dans lesquelles je vais leur
faire parce que là au moins je prends
des risques c'est-à-dire qu'avant
ah ben quand j'ai fait domitia moulin la
première fois j'ai signé un contrat pour
13 épisodes 13 épisodes que je n'ai pas
lu que je les aime vous aime pas que
j'aime pas le mettant en scène où je
laime c'est une équipe qu'on disait tu
pars au turbin tu vas au machin et tu
travailles tu nous emmerdes pas la fin
de cette fois ci je suis je suis tu
parce que moi je chapeau de la série
j'en écris jo non responsable de
l'écriture je vais essayer d'en réaliser
un ou deux et c'est vachement plus
intéressant parce que vous ça me permet
de bien voir la santé du commissaire
moulin
ça me pousse à boucher et du commissaire
boucher
la bruche et des corrections de ne rien
rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous mettez
un pouce bleus